Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The earliest man? Remarkable discovery in Sussex. A skull millions of years old. One of the most important prehistoric finds of our time has been made in Sussex. In spite of the extreme secrecy of the authorities who are in possession of the relic, the news is leaking out and is causing great excitement among scientists, although there are very few even among geologists and anthropologists who have any first-hand information. The facts are that a few weeks ago, men quarrying in a deep gravel pit turned up a human skull. It was in fragments, but there was enough of it for the experts to
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。最早的人类？萨塞克斯郡的惊人发现。一颗数百万年前的头骨。我们时代最重要的史前发现之一在萨塞克斯郡被挖掘出来。尽管掌握这件遗物的当局极度保密，但消息还是泄露了出来，并在科学家中引起了极大的轰动，尽管即使在地质学家和人类学家中，也只有极少数人掌握第一手资料。事实是，几周前，工人们在深处的砾石坑中挖掘时发现了一颗人类头骨。它已经破碎，但足以让专家们
form a conclusive judgment. It turns out to be the skull of a Paleolithic man and is by far the earliest trace of mankind that has yet been found in England. It was found in association with the bones of one of the most ancient types of elephant. The stratum in which it lay was the beach of a very old riverbed. There is no doubt at all of its authenticity. The skull resembles the Neanderthal specimen, but belongs to a much lower and more primitive type of mankind even than that. The experts have been able to come to a definite judgment as to the kind of brain once housed in these amazing bones. It was certainly a very different brain to that possessed by any living race. The experts will not venture an opinion as
做出结论性的判断。事实证明，这是旧石器时代人类的头骨，是迄今为止在英国发现的最早的人类痕迹。它与一种最古老的大象的骨骼一起被发现。它所在的岩层是一条非常古老的河床的河滩。其真实性毫无疑问。这颗头骨类似于尼安德特人的标本，但属于比那更低级、更原始的人类类型。专家们已经能够对这些神奇骨骼中曾经容纳的大脑类型做出明确的判断。它肯定与任何现存种族的大脑截然不同。专家们不敢断言
to the date of the Sussex Man, but most probably he lived millions of years ago. So that was a newspaper that is never wrong, the Manchester Guardian, on the 21st of November, 1912. Tom, we are a couple of years before the outbreak of the First World War. The scene, memorably painted in poems and novels and film retrospectives, the endless summer before the deluge. And we're in East Sussex, you know, bucolic pastoral part of England, near the village of Piltdown. And as the Manchester Guardian is telling its liberal-minded readers,
萨塞克斯人的年代，但很可能他生活在数百万年前。以上就是那份从不出错的报纸——《曼彻斯特卫报》1912年11月21日的报道。汤姆，我们正处于第一次世界大战爆发前几年。那个场景，在诗歌、小说和电影回顾中被令人难忘地描绘出来，那是大洪水前的无尽夏天。我们身处东萨塞克斯郡，你知道的，那是英国一个田园牧歌般的地方，靠近皮尔特当村。正如《曼彻斯特卫报》告诉其自由派读者那样，
somebody has turned up an extraordinary find, this skull of a prehistoric man. Yeah. So actually, the summer of 1912 was notoriously dreadful. The entire cricket season was pretty much rained off, which is why I know about it. Oh, what a tragedy. But there is kind of light and the gloom, and there is the huge excitement of this incredible
有人发现了一个非凡的发现，这颗史前人类的头骨。是的。事实上，1912年的夏天非常糟糕。整个板球赛季几乎都被雨水冲刷掉了，这就是我了解它的原因。哦，真是个悲剧。但在阴霾中有一种光亮，那就是这个令人难以置信的
paleontological discovery. A prehistoric skull, but there's also a jawbone, there are teeth, there are primitive tools. And very excitingly, the skull seems to be kind of humanoid, resembling that of a modern human with a brain size, perhaps two thirds that of a modern human is the estimate. But the jawbone is more like that of a chimpanzee. So Piltdown Man, as this creature comes to be called, seems to be a missing link, kind of halfway between modern humans and apes or whatever. No wonder the Guardian was so excited. Yeah, very, very exciting. And in fact, it's so exciting that there's a painter called John Cook,
古生物学发现带来的巨大兴奋。一颗史前头骨，但还有下颚骨、牙齿和原始工具。非常令人兴奋的是，这颗头骨看起来像是类人生物，类似于现代人类，估计大脑大小约为现代人类的三分之二。但下颚骨更像黑猩猩的。所以，皮尔特当人，正如这个生物后来被称为的那样，似乎是一个缺失的环节，介于现代人类和猿类之间，或者类似的东西。难怪《卫报》如此兴奋。是的，非常非常令人兴奋。事实上，它太令人兴奋了，以至于有一位名叫约翰·库克的画家，
who in 1915 does this kind of very dramatic portrayal of all the various figures involved in the discovery, the scientists and so on. And they're in a room, crouched over a table, gazing at the various fragments of the bones. And on the back behind them, there is a picture of the greatest of all English biologists and scientists, Charles Darwin. And so this is reflection of the way in which, by now in 1915, of course, the Great War has broken out, but it remains a source of enormous national pride because it seems to back up Darwin's theories. And Darwin, of course, is English. But also this skull in the Guardian is very keen on this, pointing it out. It's much older than the skull
他在1915年对参与这一发现的所有相关人物，如科学家等，进行了非常戏剧性的描绘。他们在一个房间里，蜷缩在桌子旁，凝视着各种骨骼碎片。在他们身后的背景上，有一幅最伟大的英国生物学家和科学家查尔斯·达尔文的画像。这反映了到1915年时，尽管第一次世界大战已经爆发，但这仍然是巨大的民族自豪感的来源，因为它似乎支持了达尔文的理论。当然，达尔文是英国人。而且《卫报》也非常热衷于指出这一点，这颗头骨比
of Neanderthal man, which is German. So hooray for England. We've got an older skull than the Germans have got. And what's even better, so Piltdown Man is described as the first Englishman, but it suggests that humans themselves may have evolved in England, not anywhere else. So in other words, Tom, humanity didn't just reach its final and most perfected form in England. It also originated in England. Yeah. And in fact, there's a connection there because presumably if the first advanced humans emerge in England, that explains why people in England are so much more advanced than everywhere else. I think we should end the episode right there.
德国的尼安德特人头骨要古老得多。所以，为英国欢呼吧。我们拥有比德国人更古老的头骨。更好的是，皮尔特当人被描述为第一个英国人，这表明人类本身可能是在英国进化的，而不是在其他任何地方。换句话说，汤姆，人类不仅在英国达到了其最终和最完美的形式，而且还起源于英国。是的。事实上，这之间是有联系的，因为如果第一批先进人类出现在英国，这就解释了为什么英国人比其他任何地方的人都先进得多。我想我们应该就在这里结束这一集。
So, unfortunately, there is a slight shadow over this story. Oh, no. Because, of course, the discovery of Piltdown Man is announced, as we've said, in 1912. And regular listeners to our podcast will remember that another great event happens in 1912, the sinking of titanic and it has to be said that i think that there are kind of certain parallels between the two stories so in both cases you have enormous patriotic excitement but perhaps a quality of excitement that suggests a certain nervousness about foreign competition as much as anything it was the germans
所以，不幸的是，这个故事笼罩着一丝阴影。哦，不。因为当然，正如我们所说，皮尔特当人的发现是在1912年宣布的。我们播客的常客会记得，1912年还发生了另一件大事，泰坦尼克号的沉没，必须说，我认为这两个故事之间存在某种相似之处，因为在这两种情况下，你都有巨大的爱国热情，但这种兴奋的特质可能暗示了对外国竞争的某种紧张感，这和任何事情一样，那是德国人
isn't it well and americans too as we'll see right so the titanic of course goes on to hit the iceberg and not to give away too big a spoiler but piltdown man will ultimately turn out not entirely to be what its discoverers think it is it's facing an iceberg of its own tom it is the of scientific scepticism in due course will send it down to the icy depths. Right. So teasing out that kind of comparison with the Titanic, before we come to the story of how Piltdown Man came to be found, who found it and all of that, maybe it would be good just to look at what reason in 1912 British scientists have to be lacking in self-confidence. Lacking in self-confidence. Oh, that's sad. Well, because as with the Titanic, Britannia rules the waves.
不是吗？嗯，还有美国人，正如我们将要看到的。没错，泰坦尼克号当然撞上了冰山，为了不剧透太多，皮尔特当人最终会被证明并不完全是其发现者所认为的那样。汤姆，它正面临着自己的冰山。科学怀疑论的冰山终将把它送入冰冷的深渊。没错。所以，在探讨与泰坦尼克号的这种比较之前，在我们讲述皮尔特当人是如何被发现、谁发现了它以及所有这些细节之前，也许最好先看看1912年的英国科学家有什么理由缺乏自信。缺乏自信。哦，那太可悲了。嗯，因为就像泰坦尼克号一样，大英帝国统治着海洋。
But by 1912, there's a certain nervousness about whether Britain is being overtaken by the Americans and by the Germans. So similarly, as with industrialization and as with sea power, so to an extent with natural history, Britain had established a massive early lead that is now starting to kind of slightly shrink. So Britain's lead in natural history is established in all kinds of ways at the beginning of the 19th century. So most excitingly for me, Britain is the first country to excavate and identify dinosaurs. dinosaurs is actually found in Sussex in the 1820s by a doctor from Lewes called Gideon Mantell, who excavates and identifies a dinosaur that comes to be called Iguanodon. Britain is also the first country to build a national museum devoted to natural history, which opens in 1881.
但到了1912年，人们对英国是否正在被美国人和德国人超越感到某种紧张。因此，与工业化和海上力量一样，在某种程度上，自然历史也是如此，英国曾建立起巨大的早期领先优势，而现在这种优势开始略微缩小。因此，英国在自然历史方面的领先地位在19世纪初以各种方式确立。对我来说最令人兴奋的是，英国是第一个挖掘并识别恐龙的国家。恐龙实际上是在19世纪20年代由一位来自刘易斯的医生吉迪恩·曼特尔在萨塞克斯郡发现的，他挖掘并识别了一种后来被称为禽龙的恐龙。英国也是第一个建立专门致力于自然历史的国家博物馆的国家，该博物馆于1881年开放。
And when it opens, it's called the British Museum Brackets Natural History. It's now today known as the Natural History Museum, but it's this massive cathedral. Basically every British child probably will have visited it. And it's constructed to convey a sense of grandeur and awe and splendour that reflects well on Britain. And now, of course, campaigners are calling for the artefacts to be given back to the animals, aren't they, Tom?
当它开放时，它被称为大英博物馆（自然历史部）。今天它被称为自然历史博物馆，但它是一座巨大的大教堂。基本上每个英国孩子可能都参观过它。它的建造是为了传达一种宏伟、敬畏和辉煌的感觉，这对英国来说反映良好。而现在，当然，活动家们正在呼吁将文物归还给动物，不是吗，汤姆？
Are they, Dominic? Are they? You can take the boy out of the Daily Mail. And, of course, Britain, as every visitor to the Natural History Museum sees, because there's a huge statue of him in pole position, has Charles Darwin, who we've mentioned is the greatest biologist of his age, origin of species, theory of evolution by natural selection and so on. And perhaps his most controversial book is a book called The Descent of Man, which comes out in 1871, which advances the theory that Darwin had been too nervous to introduce in The Origin of Species that humans, just like every other animal, are a product of evolution. And so this opens up all kinds of tantalizing and sensitive questions, among which is the
是吗，多米尼克？是吗？你可以把男孩带出《每日邮报》。当然，正如每一位参观自然历史博物馆的游客所看到的那样，因为那里有一个巨大的他的雕像占据着显眼的位置，英国拥有查尔斯·达尔文，我们提到过他是他那个时代最伟大的生物学家，《物种起源》、自然选择进化论等等。也许他最具争议的书是一本名为《人类的由来》的书，出版于1871年，它提出了达尔文在《物种起源》中过于紧张而不敢引入的理论，即人类就像其他所有动物一样，是进化的产物。因此，这引发了各种诱人且敏感的问题，其中之一是
question of, is there a single human race, or are there multiple races? Darwin himself thinks that all humans belong to the same race, has the same origin point, but it kind of encourages Darwin's peers to view human history as a kind of struggle. Yeah, of course, competition. So this will go on to have very, very dark implications with the Nazis and so on. Yeah. But these ideas are kind of percolating around long before the Nazis. So famously, it's not Darwin who comes up with the phrase survival of the fittest, but Herbert Spencer. And he writes, this survival of the fittest, which I have here sought to express in mechanical terms, is that which Mr. Darwin has called natural selection or the preservation of favoured races in the struggle for life.
关于人类是一个单一的种族，还是有多个种族的问题？达尔文本人认为所有人类都属于同一个种族，有同一个起源点，但这在某种程度上鼓励了达尔文的同僚们将人类历史视为一种斗争。是的，当然，竞争。所以这后来会对纳粹等产生非常非常黑暗的影响。是的。但这些想法在纳粹出现之前很久就已经在酝酿了。众所周知，提出“适者生存”这一短语的并不是达尔文，而是赫伯特·斯宾塞。他写道，这种“适者生存”，我在这里试图用机械术语来表达，就是达尔文先生所说的自然选择，或者在生存斗争中优胜劣汰的保存。
And so this, of course, is very, very flattering to the British, who at the time count themselves the top nation. They've produced the top scientist. It's all great. But of course, there is also a warning, which is what happens if they start falling behind in the struggle for life? Will they be history? So this is all kind of part of the intellectual background. And certainly there are alarming signs in the field of natural history that Britain's lead is starting to slip. So to look, for example, at dinosaurs. Unfortunately for Britain, much more spectacular finds are being uncovered in the continent, for instance. So in 1878, the Iguanodon, which Mantel had found in Sussex,
所以，这当然对当时的英国人非常非常恭维，他们认为自己是顶级国家。他们培养了顶级科学家。这一切都很棒。但当然，也有一个警告，那就是如果他们在生存斗争中开始落后会发生什么？他们会成为历史吗？所以这一切都是知识背景的一部分。当然，在自然历史领域有一些令人担忧的迹象表明英国的领先地位开始下滑。例如，看看恐龙。不幸的是，对于英国来说，大陆上正在发现更壮观的发现。例如，1878年，曼特尔在萨塞克斯郡发现的禽龙，
an incredible find is made in Belgium, in the town of Bernissar, where dozens of Iguanodons, 29 I think in total, are found down a mine shaft. And in America, the finds are even larger. And the most famous of these, which again, anyone who's been to the Natural History Museum will remember, is this huge cast of a Diplodocus, which has been excavated by Andrew Carnegie. I'm just going to say it's a diplodocus. All right. Okay. Whatever. It's been dug up in America. Andrew Carnegie, this Scott-turned-American monopolist, the richest man in the world, he makes a cast of it and gives it back to the Natural History Museum. So it's kind of like the Titanic, Dominic. It's a kind of Anglo-American fusion. It's an attempt to build a sense of Atlantic identity that nevertheless makes the British feel slightly
在比利时的贝尔尼萨尔镇做出了一个令人难以置信的发现，在那里，几十只禽龙，我想总共有29只，是在一个矿井下发现的。而在美国，发现的规模甚至更大。其中最著名的是，同样，任何去过自然历史博物馆的人都会记得，这是一具巨大的梁龙模型，是由安德鲁·卡内基挖掘出来的。我只是想说它是梁龙。好吧。好的。随便吧。它是在美国被挖出来的。安德鲁·卡内基，这位苏格兰裔美国垄断者，世界上最富有的人，他制作了一个模型并将其赠送给自然历史博物馆。所以这有点像泰坦尼克号，多米尼克。这是一种英美融合。这是一种试图建立大西洋身份认同的尝试，但尽管如此，还是让英国人感到略微
like they're being put in the shade by American advances. And then, of course, you have human fossils. And this is very much a live area, not least because of Darwin's book about it. But the idea that humans have evolved, you need fossil evidence for it. And this has begun to appear over the course of the second half of the 19th century. So in 1856, a skull has been found in the Neander Valley, the Neanderthal. So that's where the name of Neanderthal man comes from, and that's German. 1868, a prehistoric Homo sapien has been found at Cro-Magnon in France. Is that a place? It is.
感觉他们被美国的进步所掩盖。然后，当然，你有化石人类。这是一个非常活跃的领域，尤其是因为达尔文关于它的书。但是人类已经进化的想法，你需要化石证据来证明它。这在19世纪下半叶开始出现。所以1856年，在尼安德河谷发现了一颗头骨，即尼安德特人。这就是尼安德特人名字的由来，那是德国的。1868年，在法国的克罗马农发现了一个史前智人。那是一个地方吗？是的。
Cro-Magnon is a place. Who knew? Yeah. Well, I've learned something. I'm absolutely thrilled with it. And then in 1886, some Neanderthal skulls are found in Belgium. So Germany, France, Belgium. Who would have imagined that they would be full of Neanderthals, Tom?
克罗马农是一个地方。谁知道呢？是的。嗯，我学到了一些东西。我对此感到非常兴奋。然后1886年，在比利时发现了一些尼安德特人头骨。所以德国、法国、比利时。谁能想到它们会到处都是尼安德特人呢，汤姆？
But Dominic, nothing in Britain. That does not surprise me. So Britain lacks a prehistoric man. Yeah, no Neanderthals in Britain. And this is a massive, massive sore point for British scientists. And there's a kind of an additional complication, an additional reason why British scientists are getting a bit antsy, is that in 1891, there'd been a very, very controversial find made outside Europe in Java, so in Indonesiaonesia by a dutch expedition and they'd found the remains of what the discovery is called java man which seems to be a kind of human ape missing link and java man is bipedal so it seems to walk on you know two feet but it has a very
但多米尼克，英国什么都没有。这并不让我感到惊讶。所以英国缺乏史前人类。是的，英国没有尼安德特人。这对英国科学家来说是一个非常非常痛的痛点。还有一个额外的复杂情况，一个英国科学家变得有点焦躁的额外原因，是1891年，在欧洲以外的爪哇，即印度尼西亚，由荷兰探险队做出了一个非常有争议的发现，他们发现了后来被称为爪哇人的遗骸，这似乎是一种人类与猿类的缺失环节，而且爪哇人是双足行走的，所以它似乎是用两只脚走路，但它有一个非常
small skull and european scientists are very skeptical about this. And they insist it's not human at all, that it's just an ape. Because their assumption is that big brains come first and then walking on two feet. And the reason that they argue this is chiefly because it then enables them to argue, based on the fossil evidence of the Neanderthals and the Cro-Magnons, that humans originated in Europe. Because at this point, there is no evidence at all that humans have originated in Africa, even though actually Darwin thinks that they did because that's where all the apes are found. And this, again, is important for European kind of self-esteem because it enables them to explain why Europeans are the most advanced of races as they see it.
小的头骨，欧洲科学家对此非常怀疑。他们坚持认为它根本不是人类，只是猿类。因为他们的假设是，大脑先变大，然后才用两只脚走路。他们争论这个原因主要是因为它使他们能够基于尼安德特人和克罗马农人的化石证据，争论人类起源于欧洲。因为在这一点上，根本没有证据表明人类起源于非洲，尽管实际上达尔文认为他们起源于非洲，因为那是所有猿类被发现的地方。这再次对欧洲人的自尊心很重要，因为它使他们能够解释为什么欧洲人是他们所认为的最先进的种族。
Because they were born first and they're further along. That's basically the claim, is it? That's basically the claim. I'm slightly baffled about the bipedalism and why that matters. Because the Neanderthals and the Cro-Magnons are bipedal and they have relatively large heads. So Java man, if it's bipedal and has a small head, that suggests that humans would have originated outside Europe. And that can't be true. Well, they don't want to believe that because they want to believe that humans emerged in Europe. Right. Because it then enables them to argue that Europeans are the most superior race. So they're saying, okay, sure, there's a fellow walking around on two feet, but he's got a tiny brain, so he doesn't count. It's a monkey. It's an ape. Okay. It's nothing to do with humans. Right. That's their argument. And it's an argument
因为他们出生得早，而且他们走得更远。这基本上就是主张，是吗？这基本上就是主张。我对双足行走及其重要性感到有点困惑。因为尼安德特人和克罗马农人是双足行走的，而且他们的头相对较大。所以爪哇人，如果它是双足行走且头很小，那表明人类起源于欧洲之外。那不可能是真的。嗯，他们不想相信这一点，因为他们想相信人类出现在欧洲。没错。因为它使他们能够争论欧洲人是最优越的种族。所以他们说，好吧，当然，有一个家伙用两只脚走来走去，但他有一个小脑袋，所以他不作数。它是猴子。它是猿。好的。它与人类无关。没错。那是他们的论点。这是一个论点
that is clearly driven basically by racism and by a sense of European superiority. And that in turn explains why British scientists are desperate to find human fossil remains in Britain and particularly human fossil remains that have big skulls because both national and racial pride is essentially riding on it. The bigger the head, the better. The bigger the head, the more British, the better it is. I've got a massive head, Tom, if that's any inspiration to you. Well, there you go. I have to have like a baseball cap or something in a special size
显然基本上是由种族主义和欧洲优越感驱动的。这反过来解释了为什么英国科学家拼命想在英国找到人类化石遗骸，特别是那些有大头骨的人类化石遗骸，因为民族和种族自豪感本质上都取决于它。头越大越好。头越大，越英国，就越好。汤姆，如果这对你有什么启发的话，我的头很大。嗯，那太好了。我必须戴那种棒球帽或者某种特殊尺寸的
because my head is so big. Massive brain. And you're bipedal. Well, sometimes. Brilliant. Anyway, yeah. So basically, this is the kind of the context for the sensational discovery announced in The Guardian.
因为我的头太大了。巨大的大脑。而且你是双足行走的。嗯，有时。太棒了。总之，是的。所以基本上，这就是《卫报》宣布的那个耸人听闻的发现的背景。
Right. And it's why The Guardian is so keen on emphasising that the skull is big. So The Guardian doesn't say who has found it. It just says there has been a find near Piltdown in Sussex. Yes. But I think I'm right in saying that a month later, the two blokes who have found it pitch up at the Geological Society in London and say, here we are, and this is the amazing finding.
没错。这就是为什么《卫报》如此热衷于强调头骨很大。《卫报》没有说是谁发现的。它只是说在萨塞克斯郡的皮尔特当附近有一个发现。是的。但我认为我说得对，一个月后，那两个发现它的人出现在伦敦的地质学会，说，我们来了，这就是那个惊人的发现。
And who are they? Well, so as you say, two people kind of jointly make this presentation on the 18th of December 1912. And the first person there is the guy who had made the initial find. He discovered a fragment of skull at Piltdown. And this is a guy called Charles Dawson. And he is actually not a scientist at all, but a country solicitor. And he has his practice in Uckfield, not far from Lewis. And to this day, I gather Dawson Hart and company solicitors can still be found.
他们是谁？嗯，正如你所说，1912年12月18日，两个人联合进行了这次演讲。第一个人是那个做出初步发现的人。他在皮尔特当发现了一块头骨碎片。这个人叫查尔斯·道森。他根本不是科学家，而是一名乡村律师。他在离刘易斯不远的乌克菲尔德执业。直到今天，我了解到道森·哈特律师事务所仍然存在。
So that's very exciting. Okay. Well, let's hope that this story inspires confidence in them, Tom. Yes, let's hope. So Charles Dawson, basically, he has the look of a boiled egg with a moustache. Like Hercule Poirot. Very like Hercule Poirot. In appearance, he's kind of very jovial.
所以这非常令人兴奋。好的。好吧，让我们希望这个故事能激发人们对他们的信心，汤姆。是的，让我们希望如此。所以查尔斯·道森，基本上，他看起来像一个留着胡子的煮鸡蛋。像赫尔克里·波洛。非常像赫尔克里·波洛。在外表上，他看起来非常快活。
There's a faint twinkle in his eye, it is often said. Love it. The scientists who work with him on Piltdown Man all think he's kind of very jovial there's a faint twinkle in his eye it is often said love it the scientists who work with him on piltdown man all think he's great so one of them describes him as a delightful colleague another says of him he's always cheerful hopeful and overflowing with enthusiasm and his wife they have a very happy marriage she says of him that he's the best and kindest man who ever lived so if the listeners want to kind of aid memoir he's very like me are you a boiled egg with a moustache i I don't have a moustache, no. So as well as looking like a boiled egg with a moustache, he's also distinguished for his insatiable curiosity about every aspect of the natural history and history and archaeology of
人们常说，他的眼睛里闪烁着微弱的光芒。喜欢它。与他一起研究皮尔特当人的科学家们都认为他非常快活，人们常说他的眼睛里闪烁着微弱的光芒，喜欢它。与他一起研究皮尔特当人的科学家们都认为他很棒，所以其中一个人形容他是一位令人愉快的同事，另一个人说他总是开朗、充满希望，充满热情，而他的妻子，他们婚姻非常幸福，她说他是世界上最好、最善良的人，所以如果听众想要某种备忘录，他非常像我。你是一个留着胡子的煮鸡蛋吗？我没有胡子，没有。所以除了看起来像一个留着胡子的煮鸡蛋，他还以对自然历史、历史和考古学的各个方面有着贪得无厌的好奇心而著称
Sussex, which is a country very rich in all three of those things. So he is a leading light of, Dominic, the country's oldest county archaeological society, which is the Sussex Archaeological Society. It's still going strong, a tremendous organisation. And like Gideon Mantel, the discoverer of the Iguanodon, he lives in Lewes, and specifically in a very grand house at the foot of Lewes Castle called Castle Lodge. So he's very much at the heart of sussex's history and over the course of his career he has made a succession of absolutely amazing discoveries so he's found fossils like mandel had done and specifically he had discovered the tooth of a previously unknown species of mammal from the cretaceous period which is the
萨塞克斯郡，这是一个在所有这三方面都非常丰富的郡。所以他是多米尼克，该郡最古老的郡考古学会——萨塞克斯考古学会的领军人物。它仍然很强大，是一个了不起的组织。像禽龙的发现者吉迪恩·曼特尔一样，他住在刘易斯，具体来说是住在刘易斯城堡脚下一座非常宏伟的房子里，叫城堡小屋。所以他非常处于萨塞克斯历史的核心，在他的职业生涯中，他做出了一系列绝对惊人的发现，所以他发现了像曼特尔那样的化石，具体来说，他发现了白垩纪时期一种以前未知的哺乳动物物种的牙齿，这是
last of the three periods of the age of the dinosaurs. He's discovered lots of antiquities and all of these have kind of shed intriguing and unexpected light on obscure periods of history. So he's found a Roman statuette that is made of cast iron rather than wrought iron, which is what you would expect because it is assumed that cast iron techniques had only developed in England in the 14th century. So to discover that the Romans had been on top of it is, you know, it's an amazing find. Yeah.
恐龙时代三个时期中的最后一个。他发现了很多古物，所有这些都以某种方式为模糊的历史时期提供了有趣且意想不到的启示。所以他发现了一尊铸铁而不是锻铁制成的罗马小雕像，这正是你所期望的，因为人们认为铸铁技术直到14世纪才在英国发展起来。所以发现罗马人已经掌握了它，你知道，这是一个惊人的发现。是的。
Brilliant to have overturned conventional wisdom of academics, isn't it? Absolutely. And Dawson has also found a brick from Pevensey, which is stamped with what seems to be the very last datable Roman inscription ever found in Britain. So that again is amazing. He's found a stone axe. He's found the remains of an ancient boat. So all incredible, lots more along those lines. And he's also very keen on natural wonders of which the most
推翻学术界的传统智慧真是太棒了，不是吗？绝对是。道森还从佩文西发现了一块砖，上面盖着似乎是英国发现的最后一个可考证的罗马铭文。所以这再次令人惊叹。他发现了一把石斧。他发现了古代船只的残骸。所以一切都很不可思议，还有很多类似的东西。而且他还非常热衷于自然奇观，其中最
extraordinary is a toad that has been mummified inside stone. So extraordinary, amazing wonder. Wow. How can that even happen? I'm curious about that, but we'll put it on one side, I suppose. The rest is toads. It's just a kind of slew of amazing things that he's discovered that has won him lots of honours. So he's been elected to the Society of Antiquaries in London, like me. Right. You're kind of very similar, kind of forensic attention to detail and authenticity, right? We will see.
非凡的是一只在石头里木乃伊化的蟾蜍。太非凡了，令人惊叹的奇迹。哇。这怎么可能发生呢？我对那个很好奇，但我猜我们会把它放在一边。其余的都是蟾蜍。这只是他发现的一连串令人惊叹的事情，为他赢得了许多荣誉。所以他被选为伦敦古物学会的成员，像我一样。没错。你有一种非常相似的、对细节和真实性的法医般的关注，对吧？我们会看到的。
And in Sussex, he's hailed by the local press as the wizard of Sussex for his almost supernatural ability to pluck these incredible finds as if from nowhere. So amazing. And his renown is such that basically, I don't know when he has time to do his soliciting. I mean, he doesn't seem to be very keen on the law at all because he's hanging out with all kinds of luminaries. So one of these, perhaps the most distinguished of these luminaries, is a man called Arthur Smith Woodward. And he is the keeper of geology at the Natural History Museum. And he, Dominic, is a world expert on fossil fish. God, he sounds such an interesting man, Tom.
在萨塞克斯郡，他被当地媒体誉为“萨塞克斯巫师”，因为他有一种近乎超自然的能力，能凭空摘取这些令人难以置信的发现。太神奇了。他的名声如此之大，以至于基本上，我不知道他什么时候有时间去做他的律师工作。我的意思是，他似乎根本不喜欢法律，因为他整天和各种名流混在一起。所以其中之一，也许这些名流中最杰出的一位，是一个叫亚瑟·史密斯·伍德沃德的人。他是自然历史博物馆的地质学馆长。多米尼克，他是化石鱼类的世界专家。天哪，他听起来真是个有趣的人，汤姆。
Well, he is because he's not just an expert on fossil fish. He is also sufficiently brilliant that he is the guy who Dawson gives the Cretaceous mammal tooth to, which he'd found back in 1891. And Woodward had been very excited about it and realised that it was a hitherto unknown species. And so since then, they've become great friends. Dawson is always getting in touch with Woodward to tell him about his latest finds. And what's impressive about this friendship is that Woodward is not a very clubbable man. He's very tall. He's gaunt. He's fussy. He's acerbic. Tom, this is unbelievable. This is the podcast. That's what it is. He has a thin goat-like beard. It's uncanny. Which I absolutely don't. And actually, Dominic, he's not like me. He's like Professor Summerlee in The Lost World
嗯，他是，因为他不仅是化石鱼类的专家。他足够聪明，以至于他是道森将他在1891年发现的白垩纪哺乳动物牙齿交给的那个人。伍德沃德对此非常兴奋，并意识到这是一个迄今为止未知的物种。所以从那时起，他们成了好朋友。道森总是与伍德沃德联系，告诉他他的最新发现。这种友谊令人印象深刻的是，伍德沃德不是一个很合群的人。他很高。他很憔悴。他很挑剔。他很尖刻。汤姆，这令人难以置信。这就是播客。这就是它。他留着稀疏的山羊胡子。这太不可思议了。我绝对没有。事实上，多米尼克，他不像我。他像《失落的世界》里的萨默利教授
by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle, which I'm sure lots of people have read. But if you haven't, it was published in 1912, so the same year that Piltdown Man was found. And it describes an expedition of two scientists, one of whom is Professor Summerlee, a journalist and a big game hunter, to go and discover a lost world in South America on a plateau. What an amazing coincidence that The Lost World was published, presumably just months before this discovery. Yes, it is a coincidence, not least because as well as dinosaurs, The Lost World features ape men who were cast as missing links. And what is even more of a coincidence is that the author,
由亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士所著，我相信很多人都读过。但如果你没有，它出版于1912年，也就是皮尔特当人被发现的同一年。它描述了一次由两位科学家、一名记者和一名大型猎物猎人组成的探险，去南美洲的一个高原上发现一个失落的世界。这是一个多么惊人的巧合，在这次发现之前，大概几个月前，《失落的世界》就出版了。是的，这是一个巧合，尤其是因为除了恐龙，《失落的世界》还以猿人为特色，他们被塑造成缺失的环节。更巧合的是，作者，
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle, who of course is also the author of Sherlock Holmes, lives some eight miles from Piltdown. So Conan Doyle's a great walker. That's very much within walkable distance for him. And Conan Doyle has met both Dawson and Woodward because Conan Doyle, I mean, he's interested in everything basically, very interested in palatology. He'd found some dinosaur footprints and he'd got Dawson over to have a look at them. And they've become sufficiently good friends that in November 1911, Conan Doyle invites Dawson and his wife for lunch. So they go over and almost certainly at this lunch, they discuss missing links. Conan Doyle seems to have told Dawson about his plans for the lost world. And after the discovery is made, after the finding of Piltdown Man, Dawson writes to Woodward, huge excitement, Conan Doyle has written and seems excited about the skull. He has kindly
亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士，当然也是福尔摩斯的作者，住在离皮尔特当大约八英里的地方。所以柯南·道尔是一个伟大的步行者。对他来说，这完全在步行距离之内。柯南·道尔见过道森和伍德沃德，因为柯南·道尔，我的意思是，他基本上对一切都感兴趣，对古生物学非常感兴趣。他发现了一些恐龙脚印，并让道森过来看看。他们成了足够好的朋友，以至于在1911年11月，柯南·道尔邀请道森和他的妻子共进午餐。所以他们去了，几乎可以肯定是在这次午餐上，他们讨论了缺失的环节。柯南·道尔似乎告诉了道森他关于失落世界的计划。在发现之后，在找到皮尔特当人之后，道森写信给伍德沃德，巨大的兴奋，柯南·道尔写信了，似乎对头骨很兴奋。他好心地
offered to drive me in his motor anywhere. So Conan Doyle is also part of the Piltdown Man set. Yeah, the Piltdown set. Very good. So how had Dawson actually come to find the skull itself? So at this meeting on the 18th of December 1912 at the Geological Society, he gives his first account of what had happened. And he reports that workmen had been working in a gravel pit in Piltdown. And because they knew of his reputation as someone interested in such things, they had given him a small piece of bone that the workmen had found in the pit. And at this meeting, Dawson is very vague as to when exactly this had happened. So, I mean, it could have been any time, you know, from kind of 1899 onwards.
提出开车带我去任何地方。所以柯南·道尔也是皮尔特当人组合的一部分。是的，皮尔特当组合。非常好。那么道森实际上是如何发现头骨本身的呢？在1912年12月18日地质学会的这次会议上，他给出了他所发生事情的第一次陈述。他报告说，工人们一直在皮尔特当的一个砾石坑里工作。因为他们知道他作为对这类事情感兴趣的人的名声，他们给了他一小块工人在坑里发现的骨头。在这次会议上，道森对这具体是什么时候发生的非常模糊。所以，我的意思是，它可能是在任何时候，你知道，从1899年左右开始。
Yeah. But the next morning it's reported that he had said that he had been given this in 1908. I've been hanging on to this bit of skull for four years. I suppose you might. That's right. Yeah. That's right. And the reason for this, he says, is that it was only a fragment and that the workmen had said that they had originally found a much larger skull, which they had then smashed because they thought that it was a coconut.
是的。但第二天早上有报道说，他说他是在1908年得到这个的。我拿着这块头骨碎片四年了。我想你可能会。没错。是的。没错。他说，原因是他只是一块碎片，工人们说他们最初发现了一个大得多的头骨，然后他们把它砸碎了，因为他们认为那是一个椰子。
A coconut in Sussex? A fossil coconut in Sussex. Okay. to the quarry looking for the other fragments of this skull that has been smashed by the workmen. And over the course of the four years, if it is four years, he's gradually found them and he's pieced them together. And it makes a kind of an entire cranium of an unusual thickness, say much thicker than a normal skull would be. And by 1912, you know, he's ready basically to announce it to the world. And so he writes a letter to Woodward telling him about Conan Doyle and about the lost world and how it's coming out. And then he just, this kind of casual mention, he says, I found a portion of a human skull. And he compares it to a Neanderthal skull,
萨塞克斯郡的椰子？萨塞克斯郡的化石椰子。好的。去采石场寻找这颗被工人们砸碎的头骨的其他碎片。在四年里，如果是四年，他逐渐找到了它们，并将它们拼凑在一起。它构成了一个厚度异常的完整颅骨，说比正常头骨厚得多。到了1912年，你知道，他基本上准备好向世界宣布它了。所以他写了一封信给伍德沃德，告诉他关于柯南·道尔和失落世界以及它即将出版的消息。然后他只是，这种随意的提及，他说，我发现了一部分人类头骨。他把它与尼安德特人头骨进行了比较，
which of course to any British scientist is an absolute way of saying, I might've found a British Neanderthal skull. Yeah. It's so exciting. So exciting. We can put the Germans in the shade here. And Woodward is certainly intrigued by this, but he doesn't actually get down to Piltdown for quite a while. And this is partly because, as I said, the weather is so bad. And it's also because he's a busy man. He's in charge of an entire department in the Natural History Museum. He doesn't have the time. And it's clear that Dawson is getting a bit impatient about this. He wants to show off his discovery. So on the 24th of May, he goes to Woodward and he shows him all the fragments of the skull. And Woodward is pretty excited now. So on the 2nd of
这当然对任何英国科学家来说都是一种绝对的说法，我可能发现了一颗英国尼安德特人头骨。是的。太令人兴奋了。太令人兴奋了。我们可以在这里让德国人黯然失色。伍德沃德当然对此很感兴趣，但他实际上并没有在很长一段时间内去皮尔特当。这部分是因为，正如我所说，天气太糟糕了。这也是因为他是一个忙碌的人。他负责自然历史博物馆的一个完整部门。他没有时间。很明显，道森对此有点不耐烦。他想炫耀他的发现。所以5月24日，他去找伍德沃德，向他展示了头骨的所有碎片。伍德沃德现在很兴奋。所以6月2日，
June, he joins Dawson at Piltdown to start on the excavations. And it's brilliantly Edwardian that the first day they don't get much done because they're having a huge picnic. Yeah, very wind in the willows. Yes. Lattice pork pies and lemonade and all that kind of thing. Yeah. So they start their excavations and they don't find anything pies and lemonade and all that kind of thing yeah so they start their excavations and they don't find anything to begin with they're kind of sifting through both the quarry itself but all the piles of kind of refuse that the workmen have left
他加入了道森在皮尔特当的行列，开始挖掘。第一天他们没做多少工作，因为他们举行了一场盛大的野餐，这非常爱德华时代。是的，非常像《柳林风声》。是的，格子猪肉派和柠檬水之类的东西。是的。所以他们开始挖掘，起初他们什么也没发现，派和柠檬水之类的东西，是的，所以他们开始挖掘，起初他们什么也没发现，他们有点在筛查采石场本身，但所有工人们留下的垃圾堆
because presumably this is where other bits might be and they're working and working working and then on the 23rd of june so that's basically three weeks of working and they're not working all the time they're mainly working at the weekends dawson finds jaw, the jaw that looks like a chimpanzee jaw and it fits, it seems with the, with the skull. Yeah. And over the course of July, they find shaped flints. So these are the tools that presumably, you know, have been used by the Piltdown man and bones of various prehistoric animals that kind of enable them to date it as being much
因为大概这就是其他碎片可能所在的地方，他们工作着工作着，然后在6月23日，也就是基本上工作了三周，他们不是一直在工作，他们主要是在周末工作，道森发现了下颚，那个看起来像黑猩猩下颚的下颚，它似乎与头骨相吻合。是的。在7月期间，他们发现了成型的燧石。所以这些是大概，你知道，被皮尔特当人使用过的工具，以及各种史前动物的骨骼，这使他们能够将其定年为比
further back in time than Neanderthal man. So clearly this man is much older than the German fossil man. So, you know, this is brilliant. And it is Woodward who's been working with Dawson throughout the summer, who joins Dawson at the meeting of the Geological Society. And this is crucial for the repute of what is being said, because Dawson had actually become president of the Geological Society in 1904. And it's his prestige, of course, that makes the news of the discovery echo around Britain, across the world. And brilliantly, from Dawson's point of view, it is Woodward who pays tribute to the role
尼安德特人更早。所以很明显，这个人比德国化石人要古老得多。所以，你知道，这太棒了。正是伍德沃德整个夏天都与道森一起工作，他加入了道森在地质学会的会议。这对所说内容的声誉至关重要，因为道森实际上在1904年成为了地质学会的主席。当然，正是他的声望使得这一发现的消息在英国乃至全世界回响。从道森的角度来看，非常出色的是，正是伍德沃德向他致敬，
that he's played in the discovery of this amazing find by giving Piltdown Man the official scientific name of Aeo Anthropos Dorsoni, so Dawson's Dawn Man. So, you know, he now has this incredible fossil named after him. So it's an amazing story about kind of amateur archaeologists and kind of antiquarian, you know, in the English countryside who's teamed up with a really well respected scientific mind. And together, they have revolutionized the way people think about life on Earth. They have. But also, they've shown that the tradition that Gideon Mantell had embodied, the doctor
他在这一惊人发现中所扮演的角色，赋予了皮尔特当人正式的科学名称“Aeo Anthropos Dorsoni”，即道森的黎明人。所以，你知道，他现在有了这个以他命名的不可思议的化石。所以这是一个关于英国乡村的业余考古学家和古物研究者与一个非常受人尊敬的科学头脑合作的惊人故事。他们一起彻底改变了人们对地球生命的看法。他们做到了。但他们也表明，吉迪恩·曼特尔所体现的传统，那位医生
who goes out and finds a dinosaur, that that tradition is still absolutely living and valid in the fields of Sussex 100 years on. And it's a reassurance to the British, you know, that they're still the cutting edge. They're still top nation. So greeted with huge enthusiasm. And so unsurprisingly, you know, excavations resume the following year, all the way through 1913, through the summer of 1914, even Dominicus, the storm clouds of war are gathering and various further finds are made. So nasal bones, which I gather are very important, and a canine, you know, a tooth, which again is apparently very significant for reasons I don't entirely understand. There are scientists in America particularly who argue that perhaps they're different species who've been jumbled up. But most people accept, particularly in Europe, that this proves that the big brain evolved before bipedalism.
走出去发现恐龙，那个传统在100年后的萨塞克斯郡田野里仍然是绝对鲜活和有效的。这对英国人来说是一种安慰，你知道，他们仍然处于最前沿。他们仍然是顶级国家。所以受到了巨大的热情欢迎。不出所料，你知道，挖掘工作在第二年恢复，一直持续到1913年，整个1914年夏天，甚至多米尼克，战争的乌云正在聚集，并且做出了各种进一步的发现。所以鼻骨，我了解到这非常重要，还有犬齿，你知道，一颗牙齿，这再次显然非常重要，原因我不完全理解。在美国，特别是有科学家争论说，也许它们是混在一起的不同物种。但大多数人，特别是在欧洲，接受这证明了大脑袋在双足行走之前进化了。
Right. So even the Germans? Yeah, even the Germans. It's what they basically, they've all been kind of looking for. Yeah. Now, there are, of course, a couple of possible clouds on the horizon, possible indications that not everything is quite what it seems. And the first of these happens in late June 1914. So, you know, the build-up to the First World War. And a particular
没错。所以即使是德国人？是的，即使是德国人。这基本上是他们一直在寻找的东西。是的。现在，当然，地平线上有几朵可能的乌云，可能的迹象表明并非一切都像看起来那样。其中第一个发生在1914年6月下旬。所以，你知道，第一次世界大战的酝酿。以及一个特定的
moment that Woodward describes in his brilliantly titled book, The Earliest Englishman. I was watching the workman who was using a broad pick or mattock when I saw some small splinters of bones scattered by a blow blow i stopped his work and searching the spot with my hands pulled out a heavy blade of bone of which he had damaged the end and there's something very weird about this heavy blade of bone which woodward himself in his book points out which is that it looks exactly like a cricket bat i mean eerily made of stone made of elephant bone right so what was tilt down man doing with a cricket bat. I mean, eerily. Made of stone. Made of elephant bone. Right. So what was Piltdown Man doing with a cricket bat? I mean, it's a question that the outbreak of war kind of slightly
伍德沃德在他标题精彩的书《最早的英国人》中描述的时刻。我正在观察那个使用宽镐或鹤嘴锄的工人，当时我看到一些被一击散落的小骨头碎片。我停止了他的工作，用手搜索那个地方，拉出了一块沉重的骨头刀片，他损坏了末端，这块沉重的骨头刀片有些非常奇怪的地方，伍德沃德本人在他的书中指出，它看起来完全像板球拍，我的意思是，诡异地由石头制成，由象骨制成，对吧？所以皮尔特当人拿着板球拍在做什么。我的意思是，诡异地。由石头制成。由象骨制成。没错。所以皮尔特当人拿着板球拍在做什么？我的意思是，这是一个战争爆发在某种程度上稍微
buries. Just a coincidence, Tom. And then there's another coincidence, which happens two years later in August 1916, which is very sadly Dawson dies. He's only 52, dies of pernicious anemia. Yeah. And from that point on, no further fossils are found at the site. None at all. None at all. And again, possible cause to raise an eyebrow there. Anyway, just perhaps two slight flies in the ointment that we could explore after the break to find out whether Piltdown Man really is what Dawson and Woodward had claimed it was. So return after the break and Tom will solve the mystery of Pilledown Man.
掩盖的问题。只是一个巧合，汤姆。然后还有另一个巧合，发生在两年后的1916年8月，非常可悲的是道森去世了。他才52岁，死于恶性贫血。是的。从那时起，现场再也没有发现化石。根本没有。根本没有。同样，这里可能引起怀疑。总之，也许只是两个小瑕疵，我们可以在休息后探讨，看看皮尔特当人是否真的是道森和伍德沃德所声称的那样。所以休息后回来，汤姆将解开皮尔特当人之谜。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, today's episode has focused on an extraordinary historical mystery, the story of Piltdown Man. And Tom, after the death of Dawson, they don't find any more fossils at the site. But most people agree, don't they, that there's no cause for alarm or suspicion about any of this, that clearly this is a tremendous find, been authenticated by absolutely top people. And it shows beyond any real doubt that the very first sort of recorded human beings, what we can say human beings, originated, as many of us have long believed, in England. In Sussex.
如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。今天这期节目聚焦于一个非凡的历史谜团——皮尔特道人（Piltdown Man）的故事。汤姆，在道森去世后，人们在遗址处再也没有发现任何化石。但大多数人都同意，对这一切无需感到惊慌或怀疑，这显然是一个了不起的发现，并且已经得到了顶尖专家的认证。它无可辩驳地证明了最早的所谓人类，也就是我们可以称之为人类的生物，正如我们许多人长期以来所相信的那样，起源于英国。起源于苏塞克斯。
Yes. are interpreted. So in 1924, an amazing find is made in a South African cave, and it's a very small ape-like, bipedal, human-like creature that will go on to be called Australopithecus. And again, this confirms what the Java man specimen had seemed to suggest, that bipedalism evolved first, and then the larger brains came later, which of course is exactly the contrary to what Piltdown Man suggests. And so British scientists in the 1920s basically ignore the evidence of Australopithecus because it doesn't tally with the evidence of Piltdown Man. But as the decades go by, more and more finds are made in Africa, in China, all of which support the thesis that it's the bipedalism that comes first. And as a result of that, Piltdown Man comes to be seen as a kind of weird aberration.
是的。那么，这些发现是如何被解读的呢？1924年，在南非的一个洞穴中有了惊人的发现，那是一种非常小的、类猿的、双足行走的、类人的生物，后来被称为南方古猿。这再次证实了爪哇人标本所暗示的内容，即双足行走先于大脑增大而进化，这当然与皮尔特道人所暗示的完全相反。因此，20世纪20年代的英国科学家基本上忽略了南方古猿的证据，因为它与皮尔特道人的证据不符。但随着几十年的过去，在非洲和中国发现了越来越多的化石，所有这些都支持“双足行走先行”的论点。结果，皮尔特道人开始被视为一种奇怪的变异。
Yeah. Maybe a separate line of development to the mainstream of human evolution. Perhaps the first Britons, Tom, evolved separately from the rest of the human race. Yeah, maybe, maybe. But it's still not seen as a fake. And then in 1953, so I mean, that's decades on. Yeah, 40 years on. A bombshell. So shall I quote The Guardian again? Do, because we've found out The Guardian is completely trustworthy on these kind of issues.
是的。也许是人类进化主流之外的一条独立分支。汤姆，也许第一批英国人是与人类其他种族分开进化的。是的，也许吧，也许吧。但它仍然没有被视为伪造品。然后到了1953年，也就是几十年后。是的，40年后。一个重磅炸弹。那么我再引用一下《卫报》吗？请吧，因为我们发现《卫报》在这些问题上是完全值得信赖的。
So 23rd of November, this report appears in The Guardian. Recent improvements in the technique of fluorine analysis made possible some of the tests, which led three scientists to conclude that the mandible and canine tooth of the piltdown skull were, quote unquote, deliberate fakes. What a shock. And more to finally, the report that the Guardian is quoting there had appeared in the Bulletin of the British Museum of Natural History. So the house journal of the museum in which Woodward himself was the head of geology.
11月23日，这篇报道出现在《卫报》上。氟分析技术的最新改进使得一些测试成为可能，这促使三位科学家得出结论：皮尔特道头骨的下颌骨和犬齿是“蓄意伪造的”。真是令人震惊。更重要的是，最后，《卫报》引用的那份报告出现在了《大英自然历史博物馆公报》上。也就是伍德沃德本人担任地质学负责人的那家博物馆的内部期刊。
Yeah. And the report does its best to exonerate the scientists who had claimed that Piltdown Mann was authentic. So it says the problem was not capable of solution on the available evidence, i.e. back in 1912. And the perpetration of the hoax seems to have been so entirely unscrupulous and inexplicable as to find no parallel in the history of paleontological discovery. And today in 2024, chiefly thanks to dating techniques that weren't available in 1912, we know that the skull that was found by Dawson, the thick skull, was actually medieval and that its thickness was due to a condition called Paget's disease,
是的。该报告尽力为那些声称皮尔特道人是真实存在的科学家开脱。它说，在当时的现有证据下，这个问题是无法解决的，即回到1912年。而且，这场骗局的策划似乎极其无耻且令人费解，在古生物学发现史上找不到先例。而今天在2024年，主要归功于1912年尚不存在的测年技术，我们知道道森发现的那个厚头骨实际上是中世纪的，其厚度是由于一种叫做佩吉特氏病（Paget's disease）的疾病引起的，
which is a kind of hereditary thickening of the bone that the jaw came from an orangutan and it wasn't even pilt down man it was pilt down woman because the orangutan was female and that the teeth which had been found had been filed down to make them look more human they were kind of orangutan teeth so the guardian said uh the perpetration of the hoax seems to have been so entirely unscrupulous and inexplicable. Unscrupulous, I mean, if the teeth are literally being filed down to make them look more human, it's
这是一种遗传性的骨骼增厚，而下颌骨来自一只红毛猩猩，它甚至不是皮尔特道人，而是皮尔特道女，因为那只红毛猩猩是雌性的。而且发现的牙齿经过了打磨，使其看起来更像人类，它们其实是红毛猩猩的牙齿。所以《卫报》说，呃，这场骗局的策划似乎极其无耻且令人费解。无耻，我的意思是，如果牙齿真的是被磨平以使其看起来更像人类，那
clearly been carefully conceived and cold-bloodedly carried out. But the question is, by whom? Right. So who planted this evidence? So the first mystery, what was Piltner Man, is now solved, but that leaves the other mystery. Who was the fraudster? Who was the hoaxer? Yeah. And there've been, as you can imagine, all kinds of theories over the years.
显然是经过精心构思并冷血执行的。但问题是，是谁干的？对。那么是谁埋下了这些证据？所以第一个谜团，什么是皮尔特道人，现在已经解开了，但这留下了另一个谜团。谁是骗子？谁是造假者？是的。正如你可以想象的那样，多年来出现了各种各样的理论。
So one theory is, you know, it was someone who wasn't even involved in the dig, who basically just did it for the bants. Right. Because this is a golden age of great British hoaxsters. Yeah. And the greatest of them all is a man called Horace Devere Cole, generally reckoned, I think, to be Britain's greatest prankster. And he was very posh, kind of Anglo-Irish aristocrat, old Etonian, went to Trinity College, Cambridge, officer in the Boer War. But he was also very, very Justin Trudeau. Right.
有一种理论是，你知道，那是一个甚至没有参与挖掘的人，他基本上只是为了恶作剧。对。因为这是英国伟大恶作剧者的黄金时代。是的。其中最伟大的是一个叫霍勒斯·德维尔·科尔（Horace de Vere Cole）的人，我认为他通常被认为是英国最伟大的恶作剧者。他非常时髦，属于那种盎格鲁-爱尔兰贵族，伊顿公学老校友，就读于剑桥大学三一学院，是布尔战争中的军官。但他也非常，非常贾斯汀·特鲁多。对。
He was a great man for the blackface. He was always doing it. Right. So as an undergraduate, he dressed up as the uncle of the Sultan of Zanzibar, who was visiting London at the time. And he paid his own college at Trinity a ceremonial visit. And no one spotted him. No one unmasked him.
他非常热衷于涂黑脸（blackface）。他总是这么做。对。所以当他还是本科生时，他打扮成当时正在访问伦敦的桑给巴尔苏丹的叔叔。他对自己所在的大学三一学院进行了一次礼仪性访问。没有人认出他。没有人揭穿他。
No one spotted him. And then in 1910, he did it again to even more spectacular effect. Because his ceremonial visit to the college, he'd done with his best friend, who was called Adrian Stephen. And in 19 1910 he teams up with Adrian Stephen again and with Adrian Stephen's sister Virginia who of course Dominic in due course will become Virginia Woolf your great hero not a friend of the rest is history yeah so the three of them actually a few more they all dress up as an official delegation from abyssinia and are received by the captain of hms dreadnought kind of welcomed aboard and shown round and um again
没有人认出他。然后在1910年，他又做了一次，效果更加惊人。因为他去学院的礼仪性访问是和他最好的朋友一起做的，那个人叫阿德里安·斯蒂芬。而在1910年，他再次与阿德里安·斯蒂芬合作，还有阿德里安·斯蒂芬的妹妹弗吉尼亚，当然，多米尼克，她后来成为了弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，你的大英雄，不是《历史的余味》的朋友。是的，他们三个，其实还有几个，他们都打扮成阿比西尼亚的官方代表团，受到了“无畏号”战列舰舰长的接待，被欢迎登舰并参观，而且，呃，再次
it's a tremendous coup for any prankster but the fact that virginia wolf is in blackface tom very on brand for her isn't it yeah but uh it has to be said that it doesn't really seem to vehicle style because he's he's essentially a man for a stunt, not for a hoax. Yeah, his are kind of japes and they involve basically him blacking up. Not exclusively. There's a very good story that he has a bet with a friend of his who's a kind of fellow MP that he'll be able to beat him in a race, even though he gives him a 10 meter start. And so they agree. The bloke has a 10 meter start running down Piccadilly and Devere Cole shouts out,
对于任何恶作剧者来说，这都是一次巨大的成功，但弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫涂黑脸的事实，汤姆，这非常符合她的风格，不是吗？是的，但不得不说，这似乎并不太像德维尔·科尔的风格，因为他本质上是一个搞噱头的人，而不是搞骗局的人。是的，他的那些算是恶作剧，基本上涉及他涂黑脸。也不全是。有一个非常好的故事，他和一位同样是议员的朋友打赌，说他能在赛跑中赢过对方，尽管他让对方先跑10米。于是他们同意了。那家伙在皮卡迪利大街上先跑了10米，德维尔·科尔大喊，
that man's stolen my watch. And he's planted his watch in the man's coat. So he gets arrested by the policeman and Devere Cole is able to win his race. So it's that kind of thing. Yeah, exactly. But that's the point. He's involved in the stunt.
那个人偷了我的表。他把自己的表塞进了那个人的外套里。所以他被警察逮捕了，德维尔·科尔得以赢得了比赛。所以就是那种事。对，没错。但重点就在这里。他参与的是噱头。
So if he'd blacked up and laid in the ground and allowed himself to be dug up, I would believe it. But the sort of very methodical nature of this and the planning it long in advance is not his style, is it? Right. So maybe you want someone who's fascinated by paleontology and ape men. Yeah. Maybe has a medical background,
所以如果他涂黑脸躺在地上，让自己被挖出来，我会相信是他。但这种非常系统性的性质以及提前很久的计划不是他的风格，对吧？对。所以也许你需要一个痴迷于古生物学和猿人的人。是的。也许有医学背景，
all that stuff about teeth and nasal bones and so on, and someone who's on the scene. And if you throw into the mix the fact that perhaps there's someone has published a novel which comes out the same year that Piltdown Man has been found and features people going and looking for ape men, you might point the finger of suspicion at Sir Arthur Conan Doyle. Yes. And in fact, you know, when it's discovered that Piltdown Man has been faked, they go to the lost world and they read it through and they find
所有关于牙齿和鼻骨等等的东西，而且是一个在现场的人。如果你把这样一个事实加入其中：也许有人出版了一部小说，出版年份和皮尔特道人被发现的年份相同，并且描写了人们去寻找猿人的情节，你可能会把怀疑的目光投向阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士。是的，事实上，你知道，当发现皮尔特道人是伪造的时候，他们去读了《失落的世界》，他们发现
all kinds of what seem to be kind of giveaway lines. So in the novel, the narrator meets with a sceptical friend of his at the beginning of the book where they're wondering whether the lost world really exists. And this sceptical friend says, if you are clever and you know your business, you can fake a bone as easily as you can a photograph. Come on, that's a giveaway. That's got to be a giveaway. Well, Dominic, there's more. You remember the mysterious elephant bone that looks like a cricket bat?
各种看起来像是泄密的话。在小说中，叙述者在书的开头遇到了一个持怀疑态度的朋友，他们怀疑失落的世界是否真的存在。这个持怀疑态度的朋友说，如果你很聪明并且了解你的业务，你可以像伪造照片一样轻松地伪造一块骨头。得了吧，那肯定是泄密。那一定是泄密。好吧，多米尼克，还有更多。你还记得那块看起来像板球棒的神秘象骨吗？
Yeah. Conan Doyle was a very good cricketer. And very keen on it. Yeah, he got WG Grace out in a first-class match, so that's good. And I guess the question is, Conan Doyle doesn't have
是的。柯南·道尔是一位非常出色的板球运动员。而且非常热衷于此。是的，他在一场一级比赛中淘汰了WG·格雷斯，所以这很棒。我想问题是，柯南·道尔并没有
a reputation as a great hoaxer. He has a reputation, actually, as a victim of hoaxes because of, obviously, the fairies, photographs. Well, basically, he believes everything. And he believes in spiritualism.
作为伟大骗子的名声。事实上，他作为骗局受害者的名声更响，显然是因为那些仙女照片。嗯，基本上，他相信一切。而且他相信唯灵论。
He's always going to seances and nonsense like that. He does. So, I mean, him carrying out the hoax seems like an odd... The theory is that he wants revenge on the scientific establishment for mocking spiritualism. Okay, I find that not entirely implausible. Do you? It's completely implausible. It's a mad theory.
他总是去参加降神会之类的无聊活动。他确实去了。所以，他去策划这个骗局似乎是一个奇怪的……理论是他想报复科学界嘲笑唯灵论。好吧，我觉得这并非完全不可信。你觉得呢？这完全不可信。这是一个疯狂的理论。
Why? Well, I quote Stephen Jay Gould, the great evolutionary biologist. What can one say of an evidence-free argument based on speculations about motive? Well, you can say it sounds very plausible, like I've just done. I mean, just because Stephen Jay Gould thinks it's implausible, you haven't convinced me. No, it's absolutely not the kind of thing that Conan Doyle would have done. Because as you said, he has no background as a hoaxer, and he is absolutely the kind of person who would be hoaxed.
为什么？好吧，我引用伟大的进化生物学家斯蒂芬·杰伊·古尔德的话。对于一个基于动机猜测的无证据论点，人们能说什么呢？好吧，你可以说它听起来非常可信，就像我刚才做的那样。我的意思是，仅仅因为斯蒂芬·杰伊·古尔德认为它不可信，你并没有说服我。不，这绝对不是柯南·道尔会做的事情。因为正如你所说，他没有作为骗子的背景，而且他绝对是那种会被骗的人。
So let's say that there are more plausible candidates to hand. Let's hear them. So let's look at some of them. So what about one of the scientists studying Piltdown Man? Yeah. So there've been various suggestions. So there's a guy called Arthur Keith, who was a very celebrated anatomist, anthropologist. He was head of the Ahunterian. And he'd started out very sceptical about Piltdown Man. He then swung massively behind it, huge enthusiast for the idea that it was authentic. And then when presented with the evidence in 1953, accepted that it was a fake. He's all over the place. I mean,
所以让我们说有更多可信的候选人。让我们听听他们。让我们看看其中一些。那么研究皮尔特道人的科学家之一怎么样？是的。有各种各样的建议。有一个叫阿瑟·基思的人，他是一位非常著名的解剖学家、人类学家。他是亨特博物馆的负责人。他最初对皮尔特道人非常怀疑。后来他极力支持它，非常热衷于它是真实存在的观点。然后当在1953年面对证据时，他承认这是一个骗局。他立场摇摆不定。我的意思是，
he doesn't know what he thinks. He is all over the place. And so it has been suggested that this is a deliberate attempt to kind of obfuscate. Again, I think it's implausible. Then there's an extraordinary character called Pierre Teilhard de Chardin, who was a French Jesuit Darwinist paleontologist. Okay. It's definitely him. No question in my mind. So as a young man, he'd been posted to Sussex by the Jesuit superior. And because he was so interested in paleontology, he'd been fascinated by Piltdown to come and
他不知道自己在想什么。他立场摇摆不定。所以有人建议这是一种蓄意的混淆视听。同样，我认为这不可信。然后有一个叫皮埃尔·泰亚尔·德·夏尔丹的非凡人物，他是一位法国耶稣会士、达尔文主义者、古生物学家。好吧。绝对是他。我心中毫无疑问。作为一个年轻人，他被耶稣会上级派往苏塞克斯。因为他对古生物学非常感兴趣，他被皮尔特道人迷住了，来到
join the dig in 1912. You know, he joined Woodward and Dawson at the excavation. Such French behavior, like dropping little bits of other bones in the thing while he's pretending to dig. I can see it now. And he would go on. He was involved in a dig that found a Java man equivalent in China. Right.
1912年加入挖掘工作。你知道，他加入了伍德沃德和道森的挖掘工作。真是典型的法国人行为，比如在假装挖掘时往里面扔一些其他骨头的碎片。我现在能想象出来了。他后来继续。他参与了一次挖掘，在中国发现了爪哇人的同类。对。
Peking man, as it was called. So I can't quite remember what the reasons are for thinking that he might have done it. But there are people who think that he did it. Yeah. And then some people have even suggested Arthur Smith Woodward even though obviously he comes out of the whole affair looking an absolute idiot. Yeah. I don't believe a gaunt tall man
北京人，正如它所称的那样。所以我不太记得认为他可能做了这件事的原因是什么。但有些人认为是他做的。是的。然后有些人甚至建议阿瑟·史密斯·伍德沃德，尽管显然他在整个事件中看起来像个彻头彻尾的白痴。是的。我不相信一个瘦高个子
would have done it, Tom. With a beard like a goat. So there's no evidence that any of these people were involved in it. And in fact, there is only one scientist who does seem to have
会做这件事，汤姆。留着山羊胡子。所以没有证据表明这些人中的任何一个参与其中。事实上，只有一位科学家似乎有
questions to answer. This is a man called Martin Hinton who in 1912 was working as a volunteer at the Natural History Museum underneath Woodward and really detested him, really disliked him. And he goes on to have a very distinguished career. He
需要回答的问题。这是一个叫马丁·辛顿的人，他在1912年作为志愿者在自然历史博物馆伍德沃德手下工作，非常厌恶他，非常不喜欢他。他后来拥有非常杰出的职业生涯。他
ends up as the museum's keeper of zoology. And in 1970, a trunk that had belonged to Hinton was found that Hinton had left in storage at the Natural History Museum. And it was opened and it was found to contain animal teeth and bones that had been stained in a manner very reminiscent of the Piltdown bones. Why? What's the explanation? The theory has been advanced that he disliked Woodward so much that he wanted to make him look an idiot. He would have needed to enlist the other guy though, wouldn't he? He would. So that's the flaw in the argument. And so essentially there is really only one obvious suspect, which is the guy who initially found the bone, which is of course the boiled egg headed country
最终成为了博物馆的动物学馆长。1970年，人们发现了一个属于辛顿的行李箱，是辛顿留在自然历史博物馆仓库里的。它被打开了，里面装有动物牙齿和骨头，这些骨头被染成了非常让人想起皮尔特道骨头的颜色。为什么？有什么解释？有人提出了一个理论，说他非常讨厌伍德沃德，以至于想让他看起来像个白痴。但他需要拉拢另一个人，不是吗？他需要。所以这就是论点的缺陷。所以基本上真的只有一个明显的嫌疑人，就是最初发现骨头的那个人，当然就是那个煮鸡蛋头型的乡村
solicitor, Charles Dawson. Jovial. Jovial with a mischievous twinkle in his eye. Never trust a man with a twinkle in his eye. And he's always been the most plausible suspect. And there is now absolutely no doubt that it was him. Really? There really isn't a mystery. So there are two brilliant books on Dawson that came out last 20 years by Mars Russell, brilliant archaeologist, specialist in the Iron Age now. And these books combined conclusively prove it. So I'll quote him in his most recent book the piltdown man hoax case closed which absolutely does what it says on the tin so russell writes the question of whether dawson was in any way involved in the piltdown controversy can no longer be in doubt he is the only person implicated at every stage of the fraud and the only one with the means opportunity and as far
律师，查尔斯·道森。快活。带着顽皮的闪光。永远不要相信一个眼睛里有闪光的人。他一直是最可信的嫌疑人。现在绝对毫无疑问是他干的。真的吗？真的没有谜团了。所以过去20年里有两本关于道森的精彩著作，作者是迈尔斯·拉塞尔，杰出的考古学家，现在是铁器时代专家。这些书结合起来确凿地证明了这一点。所以我引用他最近的一本书《皮尔特道人骗局：结案》，它完全名副其实。所以拉塞尔写道：道森是否以任何方式参与了皮尔特道争议的问题，已不再有疑问。他是骗局每个阶段都涉及的唯一一个人，也是唯一一个拥有手段、机会，并且据我们所知，在没有幸存个人信件或签署的供词的情况下，拥有动机的人。然而，汤姆，他是一个了不起的人。每个人都说他很聪明。他过去发现了所有这些令人惊叹且非常可信的文物。怎么可能有人相信这个？这听起来像是一个为他量身定做的角色，不是吗？对。
as we can ascertain in the absence of surviving personal correspondence or indeed of a signed confession motive. And yet, Tom, he's a tremendous fellow. Everybody says he's brilliant. He's found all these amazing and very plausible artefacts in the past. How could anyone possibly believe this? It would sound like a character for him, wouldn't it? Right.
所以尽管在挖掘现场工作的科学家喜欢他，但很明显他有非常、非常无耻的一面，而且他在苏塞克斯古物研究圈子里非常不受欢迎。所以我提到了苏塞克斯考古学会。他和他们发生过巨大的冲突。城堡小屋，他住的那个位于苏塞克斯城堡脚下的美妙房子，最初是苏塞克斯考古学会的总部，他们雇佣他去和房东谈判更好的条件。结果他背着他们为自己谈判了一份长期合同，然后把苏塞克斯考古学会赶了出去。
So despite the fact that the scientists who work on the dig like him, it's clear that he has a very, very unscrupulous side and he has made himself very unpopular with Sussex antiquarian circles. So I mentioned the Sussex Archaeological Society. He had had a massive bust up with them. And Castle Lodge, this wonderful house at the foot of Sussex Castle that he lives in, had originally been the headquarters of the Sussex Archaeological Society and they had employed him to negotiate them a better deal with the landlord. And he'd gone behind their backs and negotiated a long-term contract for himself and then evicted the Sussex Archaeological Society.
汤姆，我不得不说，我觉得他很聪明。我喜欢听他的故事。我和他会相处得非常融洽。是的，好吧，所以我说他似乎没怎么做法律工作，但这显示了利用产权转让技能的巨大能力。他本应该在法国大革命中领导国民警卫队，而不是那个软弱的拉法耶特。他本可以解决问题的。
Tom, I have to say, I think he's brilliant. I love the sound of him. He and I would get on tremendously. Yeah, well, so I said that he didn't seem to be doing much law, but that shows tremendous ability to leverage conveyancing skills. He should have been leading the National Guard in the French Revolution, so that absolutely wet weekend Lafayette. He'd have sorted out.
所以有这些。但正如你所说，还有所有那些让他获得“苏塞克斯巫师”绰号的发现。是的。基本上，你知道，魔法，当你审视它时，它总是证明并非看起来那样。苏塞克斯也是如此。基本上，你知道，魔法，当你审视它时，它总是证明并非看起来那样。他的发现也是如此。所以迈尔斯·拉塞尔查看了他所有的发现，并相当确凿地证明了其中至少有33个是
So there's that. But there's also, as you said, all these finds that have given him the moniker of the Wizard of Sussex. Yeah. And basically, you know, magic, when you look at it, it always turns out not to be quite what it seems. And it's the same of Sussex. And basically, you know, magic, when you look at it, it always turns out not to be quite what it seems. And it's the same with his finds. So Mars Russell has looked at all the finds he made and pretty conclusively demonstrated that at least 33 of them are
明显的伪造品。什么？哦，不。除了皮尔特道人，我提到了白垩纪哺乳动物的化石。所以认为这种哺乳动物是一个新的、以前未被发现的物种的全部依据是它的牙齿相当磨损。当拉塞尔去查看它们时，发现它们是以与皮尔特道人牙齿完全相同的方式被磨平的。所以是蓄意伪造。有趣的是，这种生物被塑造成了一个缺失的环节。所以早在道森职业生涯的早期，他显然就已经沿着这些路线前进了。那个罗马小雕像，你还记得吗，那是铸铁做的？是的。它之所以是铸铁做的，是因为它是现代复制品。哦，当时没有人发现吗？当时没有人发现
clearly fakes. What? Oh no. So in addition to Piltdown Man, I mentioned the fossil of the Cretaceous mammal. So the whole basis for thinking that this mammal is a new, previously undiscovered species is the fact that its teeth are quite worn. And when Russell went and looked at them, it turned out that they had been filed down in exactly the same way that the teeth of Piltdown Man had been filed down. So a deliberate fake. And what's interesting about that was that this creature was cast as a missing link. So very early on in Dawson's career, he's obviously already kind of moving along these lines. The Roman statuette, you remember that, that was made of cast iron? Yeah. The reason it's made of cast iron is because it's a modern copy. Oh, no one spotted this at the time? No one spotted it
因为，好吧，我们一会儿会谈到他是如何逃脱这一切的。但继续列举，砖块、斧头、船，都被篡改了，燧石里的木乃伊蟾蜍。我的意思是，你说，我不知道这怎么可能。这不可能。这显然是伪造的。所以基本上他在职业生涯中做的是，他开发了某些技术。这些技术是，正如皮尔特道人一样，他总是对他在哪里以及何时做出发现采取一种刻意的模糊态度。他还不断声称这些发现最初是由匿名工人做出的，当然这些工人后来找不到，因为他说，你知道，四年之后，
at the time because, well, we'll come to how he's able to get away with all this in a minute. But just to continue the list, the brick, the axe, the boat, all doctored, the mummified toad inside a flint. I mean, you said, I don't know how that's possible. It isn't possible. It's clearly a fake. So basically what he's doing over the course of his career, he's developed certain techniques. And these are that as with Piltdown Man, he always adopts a kind of studied vagueness as to where and when he'd made his finds. He's also constantly claiming that the finds had originally been made by anonymous workmen, who then of course can't be found because he's saying, you know, four years afterwards,
你不可能找到那些工人。所以这掩盖了过程。他还在拉拢那些可以作为他傀儡的学者方面极其熟练。伍德沃德就是这方面的典范，但还有其他人。最重要的是，他所做的事情，也就是每个骗子都会做的事情，就是给受害者他们想要找到的东西。因为当然他们会分享发现的成果，对吧？但他也知道他们的工作方向，知道他们急于找到什么，然后他就制造出来。
you couldn't possibly find the workmen. So that kind of obscures the process. He's also unbelievably skillful at roping in academics who can serve him as his dupes. So Woodward would be the paradigm of this, but there are others as well. And above all, what he's doing, which is what every confidence trickster does, is he is giving the victims what they want to find. Because of course they will share in the discoveries, right? But also he knows the way their work is leading and he knows what they're anxious to find, and he produces it.
我的意思是，他非常了解古生物学。所以他知道英国科学家最想要的是一个在英国发现的大头缺失环节，原因就是我们在上半部分看到的那些。这正是他所提供的。现在，你可能会问，你知道，他的动机是什么？我认为动机非常明确。他像所有业余爱好者一样，想要专业地位，是的，他特别想要，我认为，入选皇家学会，这是英国科学的最高机构，他想要一个爵士头衔，像你一样。是的，非常相似。是的，我对他有一种感觉，嗯，所以我认为他意识到要赢得其中一个
I mean, he is very knowledgeable about paleontology. And so he knows that what British scientists want more than anything else is a large headed missing link found in Britain for all the reasons that we looked in the first half. This is exactly what he serves up. Now, you may ask, you know, what is his motive? And the motive, I think, is very clear. He wants, like all amateurs professional status yeah he wants specifically i think election to the royal society which is the supreme body of british science and he wants a knighthood like you yeah very similar yeah i have a certain amount of feeling for him um and so i think he's come to realize that to have a chance of winning either
或两者都有机会，他需要一些非常、非常壮观的东西。这就是皮尔特道人的由来，因为，你知道，人类起源是一个如此宏大的主题，它会产生足够的共鸣，可能会为他赢得奖励。迈尔斯·拉塞尔提出了一个我认为完全令人信服的论点，即实际上他在1911年与柯南·道尔共进午餐时，当柯南·道尔告诉他关于《失落的世界》的计划时，他想到了皮尔特道人的主意。他们谈到了缺失的环节和猿人。所以我读一下拉塞尔的话。他说，这是道森的启示时刻，意识到他有了大发现。他迄今为止的大部分古物研究生涯都花在为
or both he needs something really, really spectacular. And this is where Piltdown Man comes in because, you know, the origins of humanity is such a massive theme that it would resonate sufficiently that it might get him the rewards. And Miles Russell makes, I think, a completely convincing argument that actually he gets the idea for Piltdown Man when he was at that lunch with Conan Doyle in 1911, when Conan Doyle had told him about his plans for the lost world. And they talked about missing links and ape men. So I'll read Russell. He says, this was Dawson's moment of revelation, the realization that he had his big find. Much of his antiquarian career to date had been spent providing people in the
学术界提供过渡性文物，技术发展链条中的缺失环节。但现在有了皮尔特道人，他要追求最大的那个。终极缺失环节。是的。而且，你知道，他有知识知道这将如何在古生物学界产生共鸣。但他还，你知道，他知道在哪里找到一个可能进行欺诈的地点。所以皮尔特道的采石场选择得非常专业。再次引用拉塞尔的话，他需要的是一个序列清晰的沉积层，其年代适合早期人类，
academic community with transitional artifacts, missing links in the chain of technological development. But now with Piltdown Man, he's going for the big one. The ultimate missing link. Yeah. And, you know, he has the knowledge to know how this will resonate with the paleontological community. But he also, you know, he knows where to find a likely spot for the fraud to be staged. So the quarry pit at Piltdown is very expertly chosen. Again, to quote Russell, what he needed was an apparently secure sequence of deposits of the right age for early humans,
扰动的原因，最好是修路或采石，这可以解释为什么这些发现首先被注意到，以及一位非常乐意允许在财产上进行额外挖掘和调查的土地所有者，这发生在道森的朋友的财产上。这就是为什么他选择了那个地方。多米尼克，这个拼图的最后一块，我的意思是，这字面上就是一个拼图，不是吗？这个头骨的破碎碎片有着神秘的厚度。他可以接触到大量的来源，无论是合法的还是非法的，因为他的角色，你知道，既是一个经销商，也参与了所有这些各种博物馆。我们知道，例如，一个患有佩吉特氏病的头骨在1900年代从黑斯廷斯博物馆消失了，
a reason for their disturbance, ideally road digging or quarrying that would explain how the finds were noticed in the first place, and a landowner who was more than happy to allow additional excavation and investigation that happens on the property of someone that Dawson is a friend of. So this is why he chooses the place that he does. And the final piece in this jigsaw puzzle, Dominic, I mean, it's literally a jigsaw puzzle, isn't it? The shattered fragments of this skull with the mysterious thickness. He has access to a large array of sources, both legitimate and not because of his role, you know, as both a dealer, but also he's involved in all these kinds of various museums. And we know, for instance, that a medieval skull with Paget's disease had disappeared in the 1900s from the museum in Hastings,
而道森曾在黑斯廷斯博物馆的委员会任职。我认为道森，在我看来，你看，不像许多听众会认为这很可怕，但我认为他在这件事上表现得非常出色。我觉得他听起来像是一个如此精彩的人。但我的问题是，我的意思是，他绝对应该因为对骗局的服务而被授予爵士头衔。对欺诈的服务。是的，但他获得了皇家学会会员资格和爵士头衔吗？不，他没有。
and Dawson had been on the committee of the Hastings Museum. I think Dawson, to my mind, you see, unlike many of the listeners will think this is dreadful, but I think he's come out of this absolutely brilliantly. I think he sounds like such a splendid person. But my question is, I mean, he absolutely should have been given a knighthood for services to hoaxes. To hoaxing. Yeah, but did he get the Royal Society membership in the knighthood? No, he didn't.
不，他在获得这两者之前就去世了。但他确实是在知道这个东西以他的名字命名的情况下去世的。是的，他确实。那一定非常令人满意。是的。还有那幅画，他是最接近达尔文的人。想象一下，当他每天晚上睡觉时，知道自己愚弄了全世界，他一定感到多么自豪。
No, he died before he got either of them. But he did die in the knowledge that this thing had been named after him. Yeah, he did. And it must have been so satisfying. Yeah. And there's that painting where he is the one who is closest to Darwin. Just imagine the glow he must have felt when he went to bed every night, knowing that he'd fooled the world.
我喜欢它。好吧，可能，或者可能他处于一种持续的恐惧状态，担心自己会被揭穿。这很可能是在困扰他的事情，因为还有一个剩下的谜团。这与板球棒和马丁·辛顿的行李箱有关。克里斯·斯特林格，我们请他上节目谈论尼安德特人，他在自然历史博物馆，是史前人类的伟大专家之一。
I love it. Well, possibly, or possibly he's in a state of constant trepidation that he's going to be rumbled. And that may well have been something that was kind of playing on him because there is one remaining mystery. And this has to do with the cricket bat and Martin Hinton's trunk. And Chris Stringer, who we had on the show talking about Neanderthals, he's at the Natural History Museum, one of the great specialists in prehistoric humans.
他有一个理论，为这两个谜题提供了一个单一的解决方案。所以他的理论是，马丁·辛顿已经识破了皮尔特道人是一个骗局，并打算举报罪魁祸首。这解释了板球棒。他基本上故意埋下了他能想到的最荒谬的物体，认为每个人都会看着这个板球棒说，这显然是疯了。但引用斯特林格的话，辛顿失算了，令他惊恐的是。这个奇怪的东西不仅没有终结整个皮尔特道传奇，反而被誉为世界上最古老的骨制工具。
He has a theory that provides a single solution to both those puzzles. So his theory is that Martin Hinton had rumbled Piltdown Man as a fraud and was aiming to tip off the culprit. And that this explains the cricket bat. He had basically deliberately planted the most absurd object that he could come up with and thinking that everyone would look at this cricket bat and say, this is obviously mad. But to quote Stringer, Hinton had miscalculated to his horror. Instead of terminating the whole Piltdown saga, this bizarre piece was heralded as the world's oldest bone implement.
我认为这反映了英国公众非常好的一面，他们喜欢他们的史前祖先打板球的想法。所以我认为在某种程度上你是对的，这是一个如此有趣的故事，如此不可能的故事，我们可能应该向使这一切成为可能的人致敬，再次引用迈尔斯·拉塞尔的话：查尔斯·道森，世界上有史以来最成功的考古和古物伪造者。好吧，向查尔斯·道森致敬，多米尼克，他是英国人，所以万岁。在故事结束时，我比开始时更以他为荣，也更以英国为荣，这很好。所以非常像
And I think that this reflects very well on the British public, that they liked the idea of their prehistoric forebears playing cricket. So I think that to an extent you were right, that it's such an entertaining story, such an improbable story, that we should probably salute the man who made it all possible and to quote miles russell again charles dawson the most successful archaeological and antiquarian forger that the world has ever known well hats off to uh charles dawson and dominic he was british so hooray i'm actually prouder of him and of britain at the end of the story than I was at the beginning, which is nice. So very much a friend
节目的朋友，查尔斯·道森。谢谢你，汤姆。那真是太有趣了。我很享受。太棒了。显然在这个播客上，我们有绝对严谨的态度
of the show, Charles Dawson. And thank you, Tom. That was enormously good fun. I enjoyed that a lot. Brilliant. And obviously on this podcast, we have an absolutely scrupulous attitude
对待历史事实，正如我们关于哥斯达黎加内战的剧集的听众所证明的那样。我们绝不会为了爵士头衔而编造胡言乱语。不，绝对不会。
towards facts of history as listeners to our episode on the Costa Rican Civil War will testify. We would never come up with nonsense in the hope of a knighthood. No, absolutely not.
所以在这个重磅炸弹上，非常感谢你，汤姆。太棒了。我认为我们应该在未来的播客中回到骗局这个话题，因为有很多、很多巨大的骗局，调查起来会很有趣。但现在就到这里。非常感谢，再见。再见。
So on that bombshell, thank you very much, Tom. Superb stuff. I think we should return to the subject of hoaxes in a future podcast because there are many, many tremendous hoaxes which will be fun to investigate. But that's enough for now. Thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye.
我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《历史的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦和我们的问答节目，
I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。